tiene entre el último vídeo y este que
voy a hacer así que probablemente ya
olvide lo que acabo de hacer creo que
estaba a punto de bueno por lo que ve en
la pantalla creo que está a punto de
utilizar la serie de de taylor o perdón
está a punto de calcular la serie de
maclaurin sí exacto la serie de mclaren
que es una suma de términos de puros
polinomios que van a aproximar a la
equis verdad y déjenme escribir aquí lo
que la definición de la serie de mclaren
es veamos si hemos dicho que fx va a ser
igual a la serie desde n igual a 0
tomándonos desde n igual a 0 hasta el
infinito de quien de la enésima derivada
de f evaluada en 0 y así lo evalúan 0 si
verdad hace rato lo evalúen 0 claro y
esto multiplica x a la n sobre n
factorial y espero tenga sentido para
ustedes y que ustedes si lo recuerdan
espero que no sea muy confuso ahora
vamos a utilizar esto para
a la x y creo que al final vamos a ver
quién es el acero
entonces ya vimos que f evaluada en 0 es
1 y de hecho esta función es igual a
cualquiera de sus derivadas verdad así
que si tomamos la enésima derivada de f
evaluada en 0 todo será 1
para esta función en particular ahora
esto es realmente asombroso esto
significa que la tasa de cambio de la
función con respecto a x es es 1 y esto
en realidad nos dice que la tasa de
cambio también de la tasa de cambio es 1
y la tasa de la tasa de la tasa de la
tasa de cambio es 1 así que en el cero
en realidad la pendiente y la pendiente
de la pendiente de la pendiente de la
pendiente de la pendiente todos son 1
así que a mí me dice que hay algo muy
misterioso que está ocurriendo por aquí
es otra razón de por la cual uno debe
sentarse y ponerse solo a pensar en el
número pero bueno ahorita estamos en el
vídeo así que cómo sería la aproximación
según nuestra formulita déjenme
escribirlo
pd x
x va a ser en este caso particular como
la derivada de cualquier bueno cualquier
derivada de ea la x en 0 vale 1 pues en
realidad este término es 1 para
cualquier n así que esto simplemente se
va a simplificar porque la primera
derivada en 0 es 1 la segunda y la
tercera y todos eso es una
particularidad de la función exponencial
todos estos términos se hacen 1 así que
este polinomio se simplifica a la suma
desde n igual a cero hasta infinito de x
a la n sobre n factorial para mí esto es
algo muy limpio muy aseado recordemos
que todos estos son unos muy bien ahora
qué significa esto esto nos dice que era
la x se puede aproximar bueno no
realmente no se aproxima en realidad
cuando tomamos la suma infinita de la
serie maclaurin no sólo aproxima sino
que es la función era la x en realidad
esta función es igual a esta serie
y bueno cuando el resultante de esta
serie converge en realidad bueno esto es
algo que aprenderemos un poco más
adelante y más riguroso esperemos más
tarde cuando empecemos a hacer análisis
pero bueno por ahora realmente créanme
que esta función o esta serie converge y
en realidad la función exponencial es
esta serie no voy a demostrarlo pero
confían en mí tomen tomen mi palabra así
que era la x quién es esta suma así que
cuando n vale cero tenemos x alan a cero
sobre cero factorial más ahora cuando n
vale 1 que es x a la 1 entre 1 factorial
y cuando n vale 2 es x cuadradas sobre 2
factorial y así en adelante verdad y
esto sí lo simplificamos x a la 0 es 10
factoriales 1 así que nos queda 1 y aquí
nos queda x mas x cuadrada sobre 2
factoriales
x al cubo sobre 3 factorial más x a la 4
sobre 4 factorial y así nos podemos
seguir nos mantenemos hasta el infinito
y para mí esto es algo increíble porque
este número extraño que es 2.7 por lo
que sea en que obtenemos del interés
compuesto en realidad puede describirse
como un polinomio infinito como una
serie de polinomios una serie de mclaren
que en realidad tiene una expresión muy
sencilla y este número que en realidad
es algo feo cuando lo elevamos a un
exponente como variable en realidad
tiene una expresión muy elegante
esto es bastante bastante exótico quien
hubiera imaginado que esta función
exponencial tiene esta fórmula ahora más
aún vamos a ver qué pasa cuando x es
igual a 1 entonces cuando x es igual a 1
déjenme hago un espacio por aquí
muy bien a la 1 que es igual a e en
realidad es sustituir todas las x por 1
y tengo uno más uno más uno sobre dos
factorial más uno sobre tres factores
más uno sobre cuatro factorial más uno
sobre cinco factorial y de nuevo esto es
algo increíble que el número es que no
se mostró pesado una y otra vez y con
otro tipo de definiciones en realidad es
una serie infinita desde cero hasta el
infinito de uno sobre n factorial
1 sobre n factorial esto esto es
increíble ahora tenemos dos definiciones
para el número e porque teníamos la que
surgía del interés compuesto que va a
pintar con este color que era el límite
cuando n tiende a infinito de uno más
uno entre n a la n iv esto también era
esto esto empieza a darme escalofríos
porque este número muy extraño tiene
digo a lo mejor esta expresión no es tan
natural pero es una expresión bonita y
sale del interés compuesto y de iu de
otras aplicaciones pero esta expresión
es todavía más sencillo solo tengo que
ir recogiendo los factoriales de todos
los números y voy sumando los cuando lo
divido verdad cuando pongo uno sobre n
factorial esto para mí es algo increíble
uno sobre n factorial esencialmente
cuando lo sumamos nos da a la x
y bueno esperemos que se escuchen mis
escalofríos ahora porque realmente son
fuertes ahora vamos a hacer la serie de
mclaren para una pareja más de funciones
y llegaremos a algo más alucinante nos
vemos en el siguiente